so in some sense that
uh you bring some prize to the table
but psychedelics allow you to
acknowledge them and then throw them
away so like
one popular terminology around this in
the engineering space is first
principles thinking
that uh elon musk for example espouses a
lot
let me ask a fun question before we
return to a more
serious discussion with elon musk
as an example but it could be just
engineers in general
do you think there's a use for
psychedelics
to uh take a a journey
of rigorous first principles thinking so
like throwing away
we're not talking about throwing away
assumptions about the nature of reality
in terms of like
our philosophy of the way we live
day-to-day life but we're talking about
like
how how to build a better rocket or how
to build a better car
or how to build a better uh social
network or all those kinds of things
engineering questions i absolutely think
there's huge potential there
and it's there was some research in the
um
late 60s early 70s that were it was very
early and not very
rigorous in terms of um methodology but
um it was consistent with the i mean
they're just countless anecdotes of
folks i mean people have argued
that just you know silicon valley was
was
largely influenced by psychedelic
experience
i remember the i think the the person
that came up with the concept of
freeware or shareware it's like
it kind of was generated you know out of
uh or influenced by psychedelic
experience you know so to this
i i think there's incredible potential
there and we know
really next there's no rigorous
research on that but is there anecdotal
stuff like with steve jobs i think
there's stories right
in your exploration of the is there
something a little bit more than just
stories is there like a little bit more
of a solid data points
even if they're just experiential like
anecdotes is there something that you
draw inspiration from like in your
intuition
because we'll talk about it you're
trying to construct studies that are
more rigorous around these questions
but is there something you draw
inspiration from from the past from the
80s and the 90s in silicon valley
that kind of space or is it just like
you have a sense based on everything
you've learned
and these kind of loose stories that
there's something worth digging at
i am influenced by the gosh the the
the just incredible number of anecdotes
surrounding these i mean
um uh carrie mullis he
he invented pcr i mean absolutely
revolutionized
biological sciences he says he wouldn't
have won the nobel prize from it said he
wouldn't have come up with that had he
not had psychedelic experiences
um you know now he's an interesting
character people should read his
autobiography because
he could point to other things he was
into but but i think that speaks to the
the casting your nets wide and this
mental flex
more of these general these general
mechanisms
where sometimes if you cast your nets
really wide and it's going to depend on
the person and their influences but
sometimes you come up with
false positives you know um
you know you connect the dots where
maybe you shouldn't have connected those
dots but it
i think that can be constrained and
and so much of our not only our personal
psychological suffering but our
our limitations um academically
and in terms of technology are because
of
these self-imposed limitations and and
heuristics
the these entrenched ways of thinking
you know like
those examples throughout the history of
science where someone has come up with a
a rat
the paradigm coons paradigm shifts it's
like
here's something completely different
you know this doesn't make sense by any
of the previous models
and like we need more of those we i mean
you know and then you need the right
balance between that because so many of
the
you know novel crazy ideas are just bunk
and you need that's what science is
about separating
them from from the valid paradigm
shifting ideas but we need more paradigm
shifting
ideas like in a big way and i think
we could i think you could argue that
we've because of the structure of
academia
and science in modern times it
heavily biases against those right
there's
all kinds of mechanisms in our human
nature that resist
paradigm shift quite sort of obviously
uh so and uh psychedelics there could be
a lot of other tools but it seems like
psychedelics could be one
set of tools that encourage paradigm
shifting
thinking so like the first principle is
kind of thinking
so it's a kind of um you're at the
forefront of research here
there's just kind of anecdotal stories
there's
uh early studies there's a sense that
we don't understand very much but
there's a lot of depth here
how do we get from there to where elon
and i
can regularly like i wake up every
morning i have deep
work sessions where it's well understood
uh like what dose to take
like if i want to explore something
where it's all
legal where it's all understood and safe
all that kind of stuff how do we get
from uh
where we are today to there not speaking
in terms of legality in the sense like
policy making all that like laws and
stuff meaning like
how do we scientifically understand this
stuff well enough
to get to a place where i can just take
it safely
in order to expand my uh thinking like
this kind of first principles thinking
which
i'm in my personal life currently doing
like how do i revolutionize
particular several things like it seems
like
the only tools i have right now is just
just but my mind going doing the first
principles like wait wait okay
why has this been done this way can we
do it completely differently
it seems like i'm still tethered to the
priors that i bring to the table and i
keep trying to untether myself maybe
there's tools
that can systematically help me on
tether yeah well we need experiments
you know and that's that's tied to kind
of the policy level stuff
um and i should be clear i would i'd
never encourage anyone to do anything
illicitly but yeah i you know uh
in the future we could see these these
you know compounds used for the
for for technical and scientific
innovation what we need are studies that
are digging into that right now
most of what the the funding which is
largely fun from
philanthropy um not from the government
um
largely what it's for is is treatment of
of
mental disorders like addiction and
depression etc
but we need studies you know one of the
early
initial stabs on this question
decades ago was they took some
architects and engineers
and said what what problems have you
been working on
where you've been stuck for months like
working on this damn thing and you're
not getting anywhere
like your head's butting up against the
wall it's like
come in here take and i think it was 100
micrograms of lsd so not a big session
and a little bit different model where
they were actually working it was a
moderate enough dose where they could
work on the problem during
the session i think probably
i'm an empiricist so i'd like to see all
the studies done but right the first
thing i would do is like a really high
dose session where you're not
necessarily
in front of your you know computer you
know which you can't really do
on a on a really high dose and then the
the work has
been talked about like you take a really
high dose you take a journey and then
the breakthroughs come from when you
return from the journey and like
integrate quote unquote that experience
i think that's where the all the head
and we're again we're
we're babies at this point but my gut
tells me
yeah that that it's the it's the
so-called integration the aftermath we
know that there's some
form different forms of neuroplasticity
that are unfolding in the days following
a psychedelic at least in animals
probably going on humans we don't know
if that's related to the therapeutic
effects
my my gut tells me it is although it's
certain it's only part of
of the story but but we need big studies
where we compare people like let's get a
hundred people like that
scientists that are working on a problem
and then randomize them
too and then i think you you need a uh
um
even more credible you know active
controls or active placebo conditions
to kind of tease this out um
and then also in conjunction with that
and you can do this in the same study
you want to combine that with
more rigorous sort of um
experimental models where we actually
get their problem solving tasks that we
know for example that you
tend to do better on after you've gotten
a good night's sleep versus not
and my my sense is there's a
relationship there
you know people go back to first
principles you know questioning those
first principles they're operating under
and um you know getting away from their
priors in terms of
creative problem solving and so you i
think wrap those things and you could
speak a little more rigorously about
those because ultimately
if everyone's bringing their own problem
that's
that's i think that's more in the face
valid side but you can't dig in as much
and and get as much experimental power
and speak to the mechanisms as you can
with having everyone do the same sort of
you know canned you know problem
solving tasks
you